today's guest is a professional mixed
martial artist
mma man you know it
that grappler that cage baby you know
what i'm talking about you know who he
is man you know what it is
he currently competes at the
bantamweight division in ufc
and is allegedly undefeated
um
that man uh is here with his
mixed martial artist coach and trainer
um
they are uh the combined do the tembo
sugar show
which is a beautiful uh podcast you can
check out
um
one of them also hosts a podcast with
his brother daniel
and that's a name
of that guy
and that show is called
the bromalley show
you can check out both of these men i'm
happy to have them back actually on the
podcast for the second time
uh it is mr sean o'malley and tim
welch
[Music]
i'll sit and tell you my stories
[Music]
[Applause]
jehovah too you gotta remember are you
jayed out huh um cheat out until you
clayed out you know what i mean y'all
were witnesses huh
the truth the one and only truth boy
just him i'm more of a christian slash
lutheran
yeah we went to when i was growing up we
went to sixth baptist i think or seventh
baptist we were which was which one was
it
i want to say it was seventh baptist
because we don't want to disrespect the
seventh baptists you know what i mean
yeah we were i mean we were at the end
of the bat this line we were barely
you know you were the first baptist yeah
i mean they had a sign on them going
into the church and said lord wanted
oh so it was they were looking looking
for him yeah they were
it was a lot of uh
a lot of soul searching you're looking
healthy really i mean your complexion
your build i want to know what you've
been eating
um what did i have what you haven't been
eating i had a crab cake yesterday
uh
what else
i don't know really i guess indoor i
don't know if endorphins or something
let me know how you have that um
but we're sitting here we got uh
sugar shawn we got timbo timmy welch
um
thank you guys for your time today hey
man y'all look
very
you were okay tim kind of you have that
look you remind me of like one of the
like a hit man or a wrestler like in the
80s or like or like late 80s
oh a gay one
but never but he would never admit he
was gay in fact he threatened to fight
gay like i'll fight gay i'll go 40
rounds with gay yeah yeah it's in the
closet yeah i mean i've been called a
[ __ ] a handful of times yeah yeah well i
mean
when my girl met me she thought tim and
i were gay
yeah first time
so we've been called been there how
close have you guys ever been in like a
nudist environment where you guys are
both nude
probably grappling i mean you're both
you know we don't mean like a sexual has
there ever been a sexual environment
where you guys have like were double
teaming to shake or something or just
even like with somebody's air coat you
know you're coaching you're cornering
him or vice versa like in a room yeah
have you ever cornered during sex is
what i'm asking that's a good question
yeah nothing yet i think nothing no
there's going to be a time where we're
oh elenita
i watched seven minutes of her swim
lessons are you kidding me
you think i don't know her
uh um no i think there'll be a time
where we're like double teaming a chick
or like we both got the same a different
chick and like a hotel or something like
it'll be a crazy time because yeah you
know we party yeah
so um
what'd y'all think of that oscars deal
man
i thought it was like a like tim said it
was a nice shot wasn't loaded up it was
like you couldn't see it coming it was
boom it was direct open hand so he
didn't drop him which was you know best
case scenario because i don't think he
wanted to knock him out right you know
what i mean so a good slap
i thought it was a good shot do you
think rock handled it as well as he
could like because rocky
it's at a certain point it looks like he
thinks that it's gonna be he's joking
yeah
and then i'm sure at a certain point i
bet it was very close quarters when the
energy probably changed in his mind he's
like oh this is not a joke what do i do
do you think rock did the best thing
that he could have done oh [ __ ] yeah
dude
i think so i mean you see him kind of
want to get fired up but i think he did
it the best because what the [ __ ] is he
supposed to do and imagine what would
have happened if will smacked him and it
piled up chris oh just boarded him yeah
that would have been bad that's what i'm
saying good thing it wasn't a it wasn't
like a boom that's the same scenario of
colby jorge i was thinking i'm like that
was my best case scenario that that
jorge didn't knock colby out hit his
head kill him so you ran into chris at
the after party
yeah bro so it was pretty wild so spade
took me over to the um
who actually is from arizona shout out i
think he's from scottsdale hey uh
so spade invited me to be his his uh
guest or whatever we went to the um
vanity fair party
and then we went to some other dude a
rich guy's house this dude was really
really rich like they had a machine in
the front you could just get money out
of it it was just like it was an atm but
you could guess any number and it gave
you it was like this dude was real real
rich like yeah they had even his dog had
like a little wallet on the side dude
so this dude was really really rich and
we went in and like
jennifer lawrence is sitting in the back
just hanging out outside like just in
her pajamas she like lived next door i
guess and so she came over because she
heard some commotion or whatever
so she's out back just hanging out like
there's like pelling out the
pellenetti cruise
uh
like a you know just fancy people i mean
it's like fancy people you see on the
magazine and they're just sitting there
you know eating you know they had some
raviolis
um what else did they have they had a
salad that looked
it was a little i thought a little bit
of wilted but people were eating it
rich people will eat
they'll eat kind of more they'll say
it's like uh more artistic kind of but
anyway so
we get to finally see chris rock right
and so and i'm with david spade so spade
knows him so
they're just kind of talking and he was
just shocked he was like what the [ __ ]
happened he's almost he it reminded me
of you ever been at a party and somebody
gets hit by somebody and then the person
that hit him leaves
and there was never really like a big
fight or maybe there even was a fight
but the one dude never had any idea
there was any beef or anything going on
and then you start talking to that guy
and he's like bro what the [ __ ] happened
like what what do you think you know
that's kind of what it was he was just
like what the [ __ ] so did he not know
that she had alopecia or whatever
disease that's why she was bald did he
not know that i think he had no clue i
think he had no clue
and who don't have alopecia everybody's
going bald yeah well it's
i'm not
but not yet exactly and when you start
dude it's going to look crazy like one
of those things that kids used to put on
the end of their pencils that's how it
is going to be watching this is the
front or the back
oh yeah which what do you want to lose
first you think if you had to lose your
back i just shaved the back so i was
like a good front profile talking to
chicks yeah you got to go with them
yeah then you turn around no i wouldn't
turn around it's a salvage yard back
there yeah
did you notice any of those a-listers
judging you
you know this party there was no uh
uh and i've never been i've been to some
fancy spaces but i've never been
anything like this like apparently this
is like the party to end up at right
were you wearing a suit
yeah oh good i was wearing a suit
and um
yes so we were sitting that space we
watched the oscars over there so we're
just watching and then that the
the slap happens and it went mute on the
television everybody's like damn
and we didn't know if it was real and
then all these text messages started
coming in
um
and then we ended up oh we went to the
vanity fair and nobody was really kind
of talking about it i think everybody
was kind of in shock or the
contemplating of those real or not right
that's what i was wondering yeah yeah
there was a guy there was a guy a writer
there and i remember him saying i don't
think that it was real
and i'm like i don't think the acting
could be that great that way bro um
and so yeah then we ended up at the
party and then rock was there which i
thought was a cool movie's at the party
he's not like ducking anything you know
i think he thought it was really weird
he didn't look like affected he didn't
have like a little cast on his jaw or
nothing
you know um what would you have done if
you got smacked like that i don't think
you i think your reactions
so fast i think you wouldn't have been
able to be hit by that but what yeah
what do you think i think i would have
been i think at a i at a certain point
as he's approaching i think i would have
squared up yeah i would have at least
embraced like taken on the idea that
something was going to happen yeah put
on karate hands i would have done
something peaceful karate hands even
these yeah just just some separation
though between yeah
yeah i'd have done something or at least
position myself like it was something
was going to happen if i still might get
hit but some you know i'm going to look
like i'm ready to get hit
but rock took it like a like a champ bro
i agree he took it like a champ um
what rematch would you rather see
mosby doll
versus colby or rock versus smith
rockford smith probably just because i
don't know how that plays out but colby
versus jorge
i think i mean
i think that plays out pretty similar to
how it played out the first time yeah i
agree well how much bigger is will than
chris
i think at least 50 pounds i know that
how tall is chris you mind checking that
out
how tall is chris rock
5 10.
wow i wonder if either can scrap will
smith is six one and a half
did you measure him at the oscars i
looked it up oh he did and then i got
bored of looking it up because i was
trying to figure out the weights or
whatever and i just went to sleep yeah i
did that sometimes but uh
yeah so that's a good scrap though but
that was it he was chilling like the
whole party was crazy it was like
like whoa i mean it was just i felt like
i was literally wandering through
netflix or something you know a lot like
a live network yeah like through like a
movie channel it was like the
kardashians showed up
yeah dude i've been watching the
kardashians from season the first season
so 2006 me and danny have been watching
it like binge watching it
and dude
it's
entertaining it's so much drama and it's
so [ __ ] entertaining that i look
forward to it every night and i'm so
excited there's so many seasons it's
crazy to look 2006 because we know
obviously how their lives are playing
out right right
and it's so [ __ ] wild to watch from
back then like kylie and kendall are
little girls like 10 11 years old oh
it's wild you think a lot of perv dudes
go back and watch the old episodes
looking at the kids i would just yank
yeah really oh wow
interesting it's sad to see oh yeah yeah
did you guys know jada was so into sex
um i remember hearing like wilden
pleaser right i remember hearing that
specifically but can you even i mean
i think
i don't know a lot of black women seem
hard to please a
and then b
i think it's hard to
uh as a man after a while you only got
so you know what i'm saying you're
already will smith what else are you
gonna do
well you can only do like even if you do
with some sex what are you gonna do you
know well i think switching it up like
because danny and i have been recently
um
we're hooking up with this chick yeah
like two weekends in a row right and
doing it baby this is a trampoline check
trampoline check yes full moon birds
so you yeah and so if you don't know um
sean has been
they has an open wife
marriage thank you and they uh and you
said they've been dating a woman well no
i wouldn't call it dating we've been
hanging out we hung out with her twice
we're just like you know having a good
time but uh it makes our sex when we
have sex by ourselves
better you know like we go hook up with
the chick and then the next night we're
hooking up with each other talking about
that moment or whatever it's just just
doing [ __ ] like that because we've been
together seven eight years tim's been
with his girlfriend for like 11 years
like you got to do things to keep
spicing it up it's a skill it's a
relationship relationships or a skill
and doing things like that like we went
on a date with her we went out to dinner
but we ended up getting it to go because
my sexual tension was too high really
order dinner i'm like hey let's just get
it to go you know what i'm saying yeah
anyway
but doing [ __ ] like that makes our sex
even better do you have other people
reaching out to you about like how do i
get my life to that situation
ah it's
because you know there's some dude
sitting at a dang chipotle right now
with his lady and be like hey a lot i
mean it's so hard because everyone's so
insecure like yeah like it's a build up
over the years and trust and like the
biggest thing for danny is like making
sure i'm not gonna like go and fall in
love with this grown lever right so it's
like there's just a lot of communication
it's a lot of years built up and
listening to the podcast but the biggest
thing is that the girls like ryan danny
being open to it and listening to
podcasts and listening or reading books
and doing their own research and
that that's huge and if a girl isn't
open for that it's
gonna be very tough to uh i don't know
you know live a fake life for the most
part
yeah have you experienced any three
bangers
let me think i've been in oh i remember
years ago i got in uh there was a lady
that looked like there was like this
pretty hot chick right in missouri and
then there was her friend i think maybe
her cousin or somebody
and they said they were cousins but they
also could have been lying about being
cousins
and one of them looked like one of those
power lifters from like the
like 1910s or whatever who would lift
like the big thing that it said like a
hundred pounds on each side you know
this chick was jacked bro
and i had to really make it happen fast
because i had to be at the airport in
like 40 minutes right it's kind of nice
and you have to make it happen faster
than you have an excuse dude
you know what i mean i like that anyway
yeah it was gonna happen fast man you
know
because i'm uh my dick has a short wick
you know
it has a good it's a good penis but as a
short wick bro you know i'm quick to the
dynamite yeah yeah and that's fine i've
always been that way i say it up front
yeah you know i'm saying like hey we're
going to be talking again in about three
minutes yeah that's what i say round two
will be better yeah round two won't be
better dude yeah
so anyway uh
so the one i started it's always tough
because you don't know like which one to
hook up with kind of first the one who
you are more attracted to or the other
one because you don't want you wanna you
know it probably has to be an even space
in the deal
and so i started hooking up with one of
them and then the other one got all
aggressive and started kind of shaking
my shoulders and stuff and like
uh back here oh it was insane yeah just
very like uh aggro and just kind of move
just like moving my like moving my head
right between her tits like that
and uh and bro i got so scared bro
i was so scared because it was a dark
hotel room it was missouri it was
probably a days inn you know
and it was yeah it was real real dicey
and so i'm sure i you know
ejac pretty quick and kind of rolled out
yeah but it was a you know it was quite
a time yeah um
but so i'm glad to know that you guys
are out here doing threesomes and
training in the desert bro
um
so if you look at the yeah what what was
the deal with that uh
with that colby massive at all that
thing was so wild huh yeah i mean how'd
you imagine doing that
hit cold [ __ ] and something like this
the whole thing like the thing of in
your head like okay do you know where
the guy is you're gonna roll up there
are you gonna put a mask on that's like
some
thug gangster [ __ ] that you know i would
i
grew up in helena montana i'm not
raised to do that he grew up in the
[ __ ] streets doing [ __ ] maybe not
like that but fighting
so that probably seemed
normal-ish to him yeah
just how he was raised
yeah it just seems so why like imagine
as you're walking it was i guess it was
just him and bob menory i just listened
to uh bob mettery on um raw talk with
bradley martin that little dude oh yeah
and uh yeah he explained bob explained
kind of what happened but
yeah i must have just found out the
location they were at the obviously
posting on their stories and [ __ ] hit
them a couple times by pop and dipped
damn it's crazy but you know after that
fight with jorge and colby jorge is just
[ __ ] fuming he wanted to win it so
bad for his team for that [ __ ] city
and everything and after he just [ __ ]
wanted to do something well dude colby
posted like five days in a row 50 45 15
45
like five days in a row on instagram
tagging jorge just
toxic
talking [ __ ] but
i don't know it's
there's a fine line between
entertainment and making it personal and
some people are on different lines
colby's on the entertainment line jorge
was on the personal line and i think
colby was on the personal line too but i
don't know it's just not a good look for
jorge people loved it when he did it at
the lyon
boom
pieced him up right there loved it who
leon spanx leon edwards totally on him
he hit him backstage at the ufc boom two
three piece and a biscuit people [ __ ]
loved that maybe jorge thought i'm gonna
go do it to colby people will love it
maybe he didn't that maybe that didn't
cross his mind i don't know i'm a fan of
both regardless of it yeah it's weird
actually this the
i don't know and then what do you face
after that and he just had a big
contract it just seems like a lot to
kind of risk but yeah he must have been
just real real angered up
or maybe a little
yeah a couple bumps here
oh dude you even in yeah
yeah you could get a bump off of
anything there i wonder how much it'll
cost him a quarter mil maybe
yeah who knows lawyer fees [ __ ]
paying colby out yeah who knows he said
he he hit he pled not guilty right yep
so who knows if he was even and then he
went on twit uh twitter and said you
shouldn't talk about my kids then nate
diaz said you just called you just
[ __ ] gave yourself up or turned
yourself in or whatever he scuffed uh
colby's rolex 90 000.
yeah
but some company will fix that just to
say they fixed it you know somebody
would help with that probably well
colby's probably gonna get that from
jorge hey you need 50 000 just for the
rolex yeah
no one's heard of heard from colby yet
either it adds oh that's interesting
like did something really happen could
have really i mean dude you get hit like
that you could give bad concussions i'm
sure his lawyers like don't say [ __ ]
yeah oh that could be it too and then
not here from colby's kind of rare too
exactly um
what ethnicity do you feel like is like
the hardest to knock out mexicans really
yeah
mexicans are dude
i'd say mexicans
i've sparred with a lot of i mean i
fought and sparred a lot of mexicans
some of them just don't go down
wow what do you think too dude same
really hundred percent
efference scadero this kid won the
ultimate fighter
beat the [ __ ] tar out of the kid and
he'd just keep walking forward
yeah something something in there what
is it well look at nate's smaller brain
you think of smaller brains some people
like some people specifically i think
are so stupid that they can't get
knocked out because i think some
smart people you know the brain says
okay that's enough let's shut off yeah
some people are so dumb it might not be
like let's keep going you know yeah the
breakfast yeah well i've heard it be
called cardio before cardio yeah the
brain's like i'm gonna want to finish a
book next week so let's [ __ ] shut it
down tonight
yeah it's i mean it's sad though i mean
some sometimes it's
yeah it's like just just go out like
that kid with the green hair that i
fought oh yeah he did an interview like
a week later saying he's like yeah 28
days a week he did an interview with a
waffle maker a week later i'm sure yeah
he said he trains eight days a week
i'm like that [ __ ]
right now he's training that much it's a
lot i tried um do you think with
davidson figure eight figure figure edo
uh do you think that they they can knock
each other out like
i was talking to um
uh oh no
moreno yeah do you think with moreno
figuereto they can knock each other out
i mean yeah i think they both have the
potential to i think they're both so
equally matched
that it's hard to set up that perfect
shot or you know a lot of knockouts come
from someone being so fatigued but
they're so evenly matched that it's like
one doesn't really completely fatigue
they're both kind of similar skills
similar cardio
that because they haven't finished each
other right i think mourinho submitted
him rear naked choked him and so that's
one one one but yeah i mean they're
definitely possibility to knock each
other out but
i don't know if they will because is
that what's next is that what we're
hearing a fourth fight number four yeah
i think they're locked up right i think
they're locked up for a four yeah i
think in fighting you say something
can't happen and it [ __ ] happens dude
yeah
no for sure you know um
there's times you know sometimes you sit
you'll find yourself you don't know what
to do
you don't know what's gonna make
something different you don't know
where to go next
or who who to ask next for help
and if you're not doing well it's hard
to ask yourself for help
now some of you may not need any help
you may be doing great and i hope you
are
but if you're not i want to let you know
that this podcast is sponsored by better
help
they're a good group
you can start communicating with a
licensed uh therapist in under 48 hours
it's not a crisis line it's professional
therapy done securely
online
and that's important
you can get timely and thoughtful
responses schedule weekly video or phone
sessions i believe you can even text
your therapist don't quote i believe
that though
visit better hell or dm them
visit betterhelp.com t-h-e-o that's
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
and join the over 2 million people who
have taken charge of their mental health
this past weekend listeners get 10
percent off
your first month
go to betterhelp.com
t-h-e-o thank you
look for most of us learning a second
second one second long one
suck one long one
second language
is hard
it's hard your tongue you can't even get
it to do it right
a lot of people their tongue can handle
the pressure from the brain the thoughts
some of us don't know english either and
we speak it and that's insane but
babel
is here to help
babel 15-minute lessons
make it perfect way to learn language on
the go other language learning apps use
ai for their lesson plans
but babel lessons were created by over
100 long wash experts
you can learn all types of long washes
bro you can learn french italian spanish
german baby get out there
right now save up to 60
on your subscription when you go to b
b-a-b-b-e-l-dot-com
t-h-e-o
that's b-a-b-b-e-l
dot com
slash theo for up to sixty percent off
your subscription
babble language for life um
are you really cornering that yarn uh uh
pattern
yeah
um no not really it was funny my buddy
schmidty came down he's like hey dude
peter said he uh he this coroner can't
come so i just messaged peter on
instagram never talked to him before
other than on twitter and uh sent him a
video and he opened it and posted on
twitter and you know a lot of people
thought i was serious but
i wouldn't i mean i wouldn't waste my
time going i don't give a [ __ ] if he
wins or loses you you want someone in
your corner that you know genuinely
wants you to win or is going to
like somewhat care like
what kind of video you send them like an
audit like a
video of you
i was streaming and i was like yo peter
heard you don't need a corner let me
know if you uh let me know i'll be there
that fight's gonna be sick i would love
you know i want peter to win yeah i want
to win you know two more fights yeah
knock out peter for the belt that's
that's ideal that's that's your
direction right now yeah
but do you think i'm gonna have it up
here that's fine i feel like i'm not in
costume enough no you're good now do you
think though
that
because now you're like i remember
asking you whenever you came on on this
past weekend the first time i remember
asking you and and like
and saying dude if you
like you just started maybe like doing
some streaming or gaming and stuff and i
was like if you started making more
money off of that and stuff like with
that
what's your passion kind of you're like
it's just i love to fight fighting's
what i like but now that you have like
another life you have another
revenue stream yeah that's
similar probably to your fighting purses
i would guess at this point i mean
there's a big
there's good money in this type of thing
yeah um
do you
do you want it to kind of
like
like
make it a little bit longer almost i'd
be like i'll do a fight a year you know
like
it's a good question i'll answer it like
this i definitely make more money
outside of fighting than i do fighting
right now hopefully you know i have two
more fights my contract fight those out
hopefully that's not the case hopefully
you know i've been a professional
athlete at the highest level being the
star that i am i hopefully will be
making
more money than i am outside of the ufc
ideally um
with that being said yeah i think
eventually i would like to get to if
where i'm just doing super fights you
know living training every day it's
[ __ ] hard on the body dude yeah it's
like some days you just don't want to
[ __ ] train especially going through
fight camps last year i did three fight
camps about eight weeks out each 8 16 24
weeks out of the year i was in fight
camp and uh it was a lot i don't know
it's hard to say when it depends when
you ask me because when i am in fight
camp i do enjoy it i learn how to enjoy
it
by the end of it though like where tim's
at tim has a big competition coming up
adcc trials you're just [ __ ] over it
dude you just don't want to train
anymore it's just like you want to go
out there compete
and then recently after my fights i like
the [ __ ] party dude i go through like
eight weeks like straight up two months
of wanting to just like every weekend
just kind of
where the boys at like let's [ __ ] go
because it's in camp so much discipline
you're missing out on you feel like
you're missing out on everything you're
just training and recovering training
and recovering yeah
so after the fight yeah you get a little
carried away or at least i do i have
been for about two months want to just
party but if i could if i could
you know two fights a year
i'd be happy with two fights a year you
know early maybe one early january march
and then this this december i like
fighting in december for some reason
it's just a nice way to end the year um
yeah i don't even know the [ __ ]
question was yeah i mean
the [ __ ] discipline with the diets
dude you just want some sourdough oh
some sour pudding sourdough oh dude i
remember one time i was on a um
what's it called when you don't eat
nothing and you just like fast think
about god yeah fast
i was on a fasting bruh and uh
i could hear somebody fold a piece of
bread from like 200 yards away yeah dude
if a [ __ ] had something stuck in
their teeth dude i could smell it bro
like i just it was insane how many days
did you go that was only probably four
or five days that's i've never done that
i don't even can't even think about
doing that bro you get so alert man you
you're sm like your stomach itself is
[ __ ] is like is is smelling you know
it's crazy just how alert you get
um
what is it the trials you have coming up
what is it tim yeah yeah it's a it's a
grappling tournament it's like one of
the biggest ones in my bracket alone
there's like almost 250 guys so it's
gonna be a long it's adcc trials so you
gotta compete you have to win these
trials to compete in adcc so it's like
the olympic trials to get to the
olympics so we're going to vegas friday
he competes saturday could have
potentially four or five six matches
saturday you win all those then you have
to compete against sunday and win those
to be able to go to the adcc that's a
big deal
are you in fighting shape right now for
it yeah i'm in good shape i'm in good
shape i'm ready to [ __ ] probably the
best shape you've been in yeah going
into a tournament best skill level built
best skill set strongest you've ever
been oh you look at you sell doritos
dude like in an alley like i definitely
feel like right now you look like
chester cheetah's [ __ ] hit man
thank you thank you i appreciate that um
yeah dude y'all division that
bantamweight debate uh that bandwagon is
[ __ ] fine stacked up yeah i know like
i keep getting asked who i want to fight
i really wanted to fight may seven
there's a card here in phoenix i i you
know i wanted to fight pedro munoz um
but apparently he's he's not ready to go
till july so there's a big card july 2nd
international fight week i'm hoping
praying jehovah
that uh he's ready to go by july 2nd you
know do you know that you're is there
something kind of brewing you just can't
really say it or you still know
that's that's as much as i know right
now is i'm trying to fight
prelim pedro july 2nd if he's if he's
ready to go and if not i would like to
know
you know pedro let me know if you can't
fight so i can you know look for someone
else but that's the plan i want to go
knock out pedro knock out
rob if he beats cheeto wouldn't mind
knocking out cheeto again uh and then
fighting for the title
do you think and other things could
happen in there too that could shake
that whole pudding uh dude
absolutely but do you would cheeto have
a new advantage against you since you
guys fought before do you think there's
because he would be the first person i
guess fight you again that'd be a first
rematch so would there be is there an
advantage that he could have even from a
coaching standpoint
both what do both of you guys think if
you go back and watch that fight
i'm not being biased towards myself go
back and watch that fight
he landed one kick with his big toe on
my nerve which shut off my foot shut off
my whole leg i couldn't walk oh yeah but
before that i had that before that
uh before that i was dude i was pissing
him up even when he kicked my leg i was
still stumbling around piecing him up i
blitzed in through a combo pieced him up
he turtled up and i went back to step
step back and my foot just there was
nothing there just laid on my back and
he landed an elbow
at that point you know i was a minute
and a half in my leg was completely numb
and i fall on my back he gets on top
lands a little elbow ref stops it um you
know in his mind depending on how his
mind works i would assume he's gotta
know
that wasn't like a that wasn't a that
wasn't me going out there and knocking
out haley on pie but that's a win right
me knocking out eddie wineland that's a
win
yeah somewhere he lost that one
yeah do you sleep like him last night
yeah i think you know in his mind he's
gotta know
he's gotta know that wasn't it's not a
win he wouldn't be so insecure about it
i mean he wouldn't get so [ __ ] fired
up if he knew it was going to be like
but i [ __ ] knocked you out but he
gets fired up but i think mentally he's
a super strong kid but i think his
coaches saw the speed that you have and
saw like [ __ ] we got out of their best
case scenario so
that's a big fight he's got to say he's
got to say yeah i'll want it again i'll
do it again he can't say anything else
but it's going to happen again well i
think there's something to
and do you think that that cheetah would
have an advantage to having been in
there with them before been in there
with sean before it wasn't it wasn't the
fight was so quick right if anything
it's worse for him that he knows how
much faster i am than him he's got to
have felt that yeah
um well what about this i'm just a big
fan of hers um
what about uh
oh [ __ ] there was someone was gonna ask
you dog about that
yeah i mean it
i don't know it was it was yeah i mean
look it's
oh here's one of the reasons i think
probably people would get upset is
because since you have more of a name
also outside of the sport or congruent
with the sport right you have like a an
energy of vibe right you're also a
commodity outside of it that if they win
or lose kind of
you're still
you have kind of have this other bravado
that goes on so i could understand
probably that even if somebody beat you
and but people are still talking about
you or you still have your show going
you still have a way to like
be kind of winning each week
in your own like world and stuff that
people would be like oh
that p that would rub people a little
bit just because i think by nature we
all get jealous you know or and i'm not
saying he's jealous but i think we all
get
you know i i think that would just be
normal i got a lot of hate for the
undefeated like even from other
professional fighters i mean
is it
you hear colby coming in we just sound
the full senpai he's like i feel like he
said he feels like he's undefeated he
feels like those fights against camaro
he didn't lose he thought he wanted his
mind and it just to random to other
people normal people
sound stupid i get it dude i don't feel
like i lost that fight i did not feel
like my skill will set
lost to his skills yeah i feel like it's
a completely freak accident
why hasn't it happened again why hasn't
he spot like three or four times why
hasn't he kicked that nerve again right
something that fires me up i love joe
rogan
but god damn it he oh i'd love to
just watch that fight back with him and
he's like oh he kicked though she kicked
his legs right out from under him it's
like he really didn't do he landed one
kick on my nerve with his toe
and they obviously you see me get fired
up about it i'm going to get that
rematch back it's going to be a big
fight um so i mean so along the way
that'd be a fight you'd like to have
probably it's going to happen yeah it
just needs to make sense it needs to
make sense my whole career has made
sense it just that fight will happen
when it makes sense yeah i don't rob fox
who do you think wins that it's a very
interesting match up rob font cheeto
five rounds in the smaller cage well i
think after that kind of thing you'll
start to get a better idea you know
that's that's the neatest thing about
y'all sport is like while you're waiting
for your fighter you know other there's
other little pieces that are shifting
and so you're like oh the whole the
landscape could look totally different
you know and what about the du jolly's
uh
more uh
geez it's hard to read a lot of the rant
it's just it's hard to get through it um
it's vashvili
you know home rob yeah yeah people
forget about him just because his name's
too hard to pronounce people literally
forget about i don't think they forget
about him because his name's hard
pronounced i think they forget about him
because he's he's a typical like kind of
wrestler yeah when he fights it's time
to go get a snack or it's not like
entertaining there's no va like there's
nothing no plus like side to those
fights right
right tough [ __ ] good
[ __ ] there's just no
like if that fights like if i'm champ
and he's next that fight happens you
know what i mean
um
yeah it's exciting dude that division's
on fire right now we got [ __ ] jose
aldo tj dillashaw corey santa and peter
alger like the [ __ ] division's on
fire
cody's coming back up i think cody's
going back up to bantamweight or
bellator one of the two will you even
forget about dillashaw that he just came
back i mean he had that one fight
against senegal that's it right that
fight was so impressive coming off the
epo everyone knew everyone was
questioning him for him to go out there
lose the first couple rounds to cory get
his acl or whatever torn off in the
first round for him to adjust and adapt
to be able to pull off the victory
but that's also a close fight like cory
says he thinks he won that fight and you
know i i think a lot of people thought
he won that fight close fight but for tj
to actually get that victory that was
[ __ ] huge yeah
yeah that's sick man that whole division
did you uh re-watch peter versajo yeah i
rewatched some of the fights they post
on youtube and they just recently posted
that uh no i haven't rewatched it i
remember watching it live and i remember
thinking that peter was going to win but
then
surprise that al joe kind of kept it
going so i yeah i don't know it was
slowly getting bad for aljo towards the
end there like there was still like ten
nine eight minutes left or whatever to
fight and peter would didn't look like
he was slowing down well peter would
like kind of go down and he every time
he was moving he was throwing throwing
just uh punches every time he was moving
everything he it was like it's like he
couldn't even not throw a punch it's
like you could shake his hand and he
would also punch you you know it's like
he couldn't help it like he's rushing
yeah oh dude russian that's why i think
russian might be the hardest to knock i
think russian seems i mean you guys
would know a lot better but russian
seems like the hardest snow brothers a
lot of people call snow brothers
uh they seem like the hardest to knock
out there we'll see i'm excited to fight
peter someday
he's a little fucker's tough dude he's
sick to watch terminator dude yeah he's
not like a he i think he is capable of
grappling and kind of being like a
hardcore grappler like he's capable of
it a skill set but the dude likes to box
like to [ __ ] fight like actually
fight and entertain which is i think
what i respect so much about him yeah
that he has the skill set to be boring
like murad or someone like that but he
chooses to be a [ __ ] gangster
sick to watch you see colby was really
pushing for the israelite sonia fight oh
he was yeah him against israel
i'll say this about kobe man he does a
great job of kind of
position you don't realize it but he
positions himself into these great
fights yeah well yeah he doesn't get
finished like the fights are close
enough to where it's like okay that you
know because he didn't get finished by
comoro if he got finished it's like it
puts you in a different situation a
different position to be able to he
can't call out is he yeah now it's like
he's coming off a loss but people are
still like oh yeah that would be
interesting and israel was kind of the
defender of the free world in a weird
way so i could see him taking that just
to go and like want to i'm going to shut
this guy up or something kind of i don't
think ufc makes that coming off a loss
never been ufc welterweight champ
like i mean after jared cannon here they
might
yeah i mean because what's next what
would be next for izzy he's [ __ ] ran
through everyone in his division so he's
gonna fight jared cannonier and then
after that maybe colby would happen dude
unless jared clocks is he yeah yeah
exactly you know you never know fighting
[ __ ] crazy
yeah it's [ __ ] wild
it's a while yeah it's and it's just
gotten wilder i mean during the pandemic
because i
you got i saw you guys before the
pandemic i saw y'all at the fights at
the um
what was the last one i don't remember
but i remember always watching my fight
back i don't know it was the green
haired fight when i fought him uh at the
end of the fight it's panning through
the through the
audience and they're boom they're still
like yeah
yeah that was cool man the last one was
great too man the one where you fought
off pirate howling piova yeah yeah that
was a sick fight that was a sick fight
dude that was a that was just a great
fight to be at too
um so you guys have had kind of a lot of
down time right dude after my fight i
think there was about two months where i
was like
you know every week not every weekend
but a lot of the weekends we were in la
yeah we didn't go to miami we were i
think mine went to la a couple times
partied here a couple times which is
rare we don't usually party here but i
actually oh i've flown out a bunch of my
twitch subscribers from they all lived
on my parents took them to the club
bought a limo old school 1999 lincoln
limo
flew him out never been to a party or
never been to the club a couple of them
were virgins oh yeah took him to the
club popped a little uh little uh
right he had him [ __ ] just dance have
the time of their [ __ ] lives dude it
was legendary and uh yeah so we went out
out in phoenix
which is rare we don't usually go out
here
who'd i mean oh i met some girl i was in
new orleans
and she's like oh sugar she's like sugar
shawn said we should bang because we
both have the same birthday i mean yeah
you and her no she said that she said
that i was like that's such a great
pickup line oh we have the same birthday
we should [ __ ] yeah it makes sense i
mean if we were born in the same day
might as well [ __ ] yeah obviously the
astrologers want it
um that's true is there any like um i
was trying to think of some good
products for different like like
different
fighters that would be good you know for
podcasters no for uh
supplements i'm kind of changing the
subject i guess yeah i was just thinking
of like different
um
like like what if herb dean made like
alarm clocks you know or like
i'm just trying to think what would be
neat because a lot of guys could have a
cool product i think they don't kind of
have one you know i'm just trying to
think of what something like that would
be you know yeah some yeah it takes yeah
marketing or products and [ __ ] is a
whole nother [ __ ] skill outside of
fighting that some people have some
people don't you uh had bryce bryce
mitchell on a couple times he seemed
like a [ __ ] character oh yeah love
his lifestyle he's that's [ __ ] hilar
like just him well one thing i noticed
about bryce especially remember when he
when he spoke after that win which
it was interesting at the beginning of
that fight you kind of saw like okay
here's bryce mitchell he's like more you
know he that's a big step up in class
just in in in the hypothetical class of
of these you know the history of these
men
so you're like this is gonna be
interesting you felt it when the cage
closed you're like this is like kind of
like a boy goes up the mountain kind of
vibe
and and then he just i mean he just
controlled the whole thing and then
afterwards he was like i'll i'll defend
my land like i'm not supporting this war
but i'll defend my homeland my arkansas
and that [ __ ] was interesting to me
because i'm like
that's kind of where people are getting
i think a little bit people are like
i'm not buying into some of this ameri
like this [ __ ] fighting somebody
else's war type of [ __ ] but i'll defend
my yard you know like i'll defend my
my home territory
i just felt like you can kind of start
to feel that in the world a little bit
you know
like people are like there's so much
dark arts kind of going on out there
about um like what the government's
really doing with you know using like
troops and all this and what their real
intentions are well it's crazy russia
like they don't have internet they don't
have their russian uh state news so
whatever they put out is the only news
the russians can see
so they don't really
know that they're invading ukraine or
whatever they think
they're they're fighting ukraine for a
different reason what so russia has no
wi-fi i don't think they do right now
right can you look that up but then how
do those women send all those pictures
to us then how's peter tweet peter's
done live in russia he wasn't like uh
thailand [ __ ] can you look that up champ
but their only source of news is like
russian news well dude i remember when i
went to i went to cuba one time right
when i was in college and
we uh the library there started
with when fidel and uh che guevaras
were in they started power so the the
history of cuba started then like in
their library so you couldn't learn yeah
anything else you wanted to find you had
to like get your grandmother to tell you
or them to sneak you a book like if you
went to the library
that was what it was you know
yeah history dude it's weird because
growing up i'm like why the [ __ ] would i
i mean
why would i i don't care what happened
before i'm just living in the future
baby yeah and uh now i mean it's kind of
interesting i don't really go about it
and look for it but it's more
interesting now growing up i was like i
don't give a [ __ ] what happened well the
only thing you have grown up is the few
like at a certain point your life starts
to get more past in it so you start to
think i think about the history more
yeah because your own life is like oh
now i got 26 years i got 27 years you
know my life i have a little more
history let me maybe contemplate it but
when all you have is the future like
you're like [ __ ] that [ __ ] [ __ ] them
fourth grade getting a boner [ __ ]
when someone says anything like whoa
they're trying to teach me about [ __ ]
sacagawea and then i'm listening to my
what
yeah yeah [ __ ] but yeah you're like [ __ ]
the mayflower the fact that they're even
teaching kids history is insane yeah
when a kid all they care about is the
future you know some dude i remember
having one buddy who was just obsessed
like a history like that dude should be
learning about it and then progressively
learning more and more yeah but for
someone like me it's like don't waste
your time i know don't teach me anything
could you have been a pilgrim or
something you think
be honest with me dude i'm a [ __ ] i
can't do [ __ ] i can't make a fire i
can't
he's rather helpless i'm pretty helpless
do it yeah and the more money i make the
worse i get like no i guess i've been
better i've been getting ripped and
doing laundry and dishes like
recently a couple times because for the
most part it's like i don't do
you got to do dishes fast to get ripped
from doing it i feel like i get high
throwing my airpods throwing a podcast
and like i can find enjoyment send him a
video but like dude i'm [ __ ] doing
the dishes doing the dishes
how often do you guys see each other
uh
five times a week oh yeah all the time
well mostly at training though yeah
monday we train together tuesday we're
training together
we went i don't know yeah randomly we do
the pods sundays
the more popular that you guys get in
the more that your life kind of gets
bigger with fighting do you have to be
careful who you spar with and stuff do
you get a lot more selective with that
or what does that kind of look like yeah
i mean as far as actual sparring leading
up for a fight
like sparring headgear mouth guard chin
pads all that [ __ ] i don't spar outside
of camp i haven't for years i spar once
i get a fight booked i'll start sparring
that's sparring grappling wise i mean
you know
if there's a new kid he just looks like
a complete [ __ ] spas or a huge guy
i'll avoid him but usually we pick the
rounds for him when we're going in
training camp and it's eight weeks out
trying to figure out who's the best then
we pick the right kids okay because we i
mean it's so hard to say you gotta i
feel like you have to spar leading up to
a fight you gotta get the timing down
you gotta get that that same energy that
same [ __ ]
feeling as a fight um but you also don't
want to go in there and have fight of
the night 50 000 fight of the night or a
fight of the night round or a [ __ ]
crazy round like
you don't want to get hurt sparring
that's where nine like
so many people get hurt sparring yeah
and it's just where
i'd rather go into a fight healthy with
let like less intense intensity sparring
then be like damn i sparked so [ __ ]
hard for this camp but my hand
can't make a fist yeah my head kind of
hurts going into this fight i'd rather
feel healthy going into a fight yeah
you try to get how many practices of jiu
jitsu you try to get a month
um that's a good question man i would
say
eight to ten wow it's good if i can
it's been hard just kind of with moving
around and stuff like that and then
sometimes it's like i got to do i got to
make sure i'm yogurt up enough to get in
there too just so i just want to be
prepared yeah a good warm-up is so
[ __ ] important dude and i kept
getting damaged up like big dudes would
come in that you know like big bear or
whatever you know this guy and the guy
always has a name yeah yeah this dude
name yeah everybody you know bear or
fridgey or whatever you know something
i'm like i don't want to be around this
guy you know yeah and the guy's so warm
you're like trying to fight him and he's
just so big all you can tell is this
that he's warm
and uh so there's been i've taken some
damage a couple times right to sit out
for three weeks you know that's part of
it the worst yeah and it's inevitable
it's gonna happen it sucks have you all
been approached by some of them stem
cell joints y'all thought about getting
stemmed up i mean i would no i haven't
though yeah not really never
i don't even know if i don't even think
you're allowed to in the ufc i don't
know what the stem cell laws are rules
are or any of that [ __ ] so i don't know
people doing them yeah yeah i think
poirier got some in his hip you know or
something oh cause he had a torn labrum
i'm pretty sure right
so abram i think is i have a i've had
labrum surgery hip surgery labrum your
labrum yeah you got them on your
shoulders too wow
yeah some people do you probably don't
yeah i might not have them
speaking of you know what i mean he
wanted to fight nate nate doesn't really
seem to like that's gonna happen
colby and dustin would be such a sick
[ __ ] fight dude i think dustin knows
that colby is a [ __ ] to fight
dude he is his car he's not gonna get
tired
he's his wrestling's elite his striking
it's weird because striking is kind of
sloppy but it's very effective in mma
especially with his threat the takedown
i bet dustin looked at that fight like
god damn it dude i do not want to lose
to that [ __ ] i don't even know
if it's worth fighting him right maybe
will you weigh out nate and colby come
on so yeah you want that nate fight yeah
you want the knee fight and also it's
like you know the nate fight is probably
going to go the distance it's just going
to be a
just
people hitting each other yeah it's
going to be a real dog fight but dustin
versus colby is very interesting because
dustin's a [ __ ] dude oh he
throws bombs
he also has good pace yeah i don't think
he it doesn't seem like he want he
doesn't want to give colby that
like
you deserve to fight you know i could
see that for sure it's a big fight you
know yeah dustin has you know i feel
like that in certain ways like i don't
want to give people big fights i just
don't
yeah they don't deserve it is there a
guy out there that's even in front of
you that you feel like this is
i wouldn't do it
uh i don't know
just give them the opportunity
yeah well that's kind of how i feel with
the cheeto rematch
you'll earn it what like that's what i'm
saying it'll happen when it happens like
build yourself up make your my name i
made a name for cheeto like he's got a
name because of me
build yourself up but you know let's
build the big a big fight
we'll say you say uh yan wins right okay
then what then who's
because sandhagen and yon fought yeah
tj's probably next oh
wow or tj vs although our tj vs dominic
cruz is super interesting
um you know
i don't think rob cheeto i don't think
the winner of that gets it gets title
fight yeah
i'd say tj is probably next
i would guess
when you um yeah and who's who does san
hagen fight
winner of rob cheeto and then for that
would be a title eliminator maybe
i mean there's there's the whole
division there's just so many [ __ ]
like
and you have to like look at it it's
going to take a year you know every time
it's like this is a year and a half
later is that person still going to be
in and what's going to be going on yeah
it's pretty captivating you know it's
super super it's crazy to think about
like the mlb nfl nba like it's like they
just play every weekend multiple times a
week sometimes yeah fighting it's like
if you get three fights in a year it's
like a lot it's a good amount
oh yeah
and also it's hard to eat like ufc
became my favorite sport like mma became
my favorite sport it's interesting like
probably over the pandemic because it
was available
and um
yeah and it was just
i don't know it was they yeah it was
just there first of all and it didn't
seem like a [ __ ] like the everything
else seemed to like turn into such a
[ __ ] fat it was just like nba is weird
because it's like sometimes like on the
beginning of the game it doesn't really
seem like it's more like i'd watch the
fourth quarter right what was your
favorite before fighting i think it was
nfl was it but now you start to know the
player it doesn't seem like there's any
beef between the teams that much anymore
like i think that's one thing that ufc
still has you know it's the president
right oh they know what you know that
they still have be these guys there's
still beef between them the money isn't
so much that
that one of them is going to say oh
let's just have a good time out here
like the nba players they're all friends
now there's just not as much
competit like yeah
like i
have to win this yeah i guess there's
probably like tom brady it seems like
that like there's there's just
competitors lebron james like right yeah
and fighting it's [ __ ] life or death
really like you could die in there i
guess football is similar but but
everybody's just so controlled in what
they say in those places like they all
have publicists that may so nobody's
like hey [ __ ] the dolphins yeah i'm
gonna be i'll be reading the [ __ ] out of
the dolphins like if one player said
that they would be the favorite player
in a week they can't say that they're
legally not allowed to i don't think in
their contracts like their twitter has
to be certain like like look at ab now
adrian brown look at him going crazy now
he's not in the nfl he can say whatever
[ __ ] he wants and he's beating himself
and he's a whole different character now
do you think he got paid when it for
full send podcast do you think he got
paid that next day i'm sure they cut him
some i think for certain guests like
that like i think folsom paid kodak
black i think they pay certain guys that
are that level to get on there yeah
so yeah they probably caught them a
little chizza like what 50 stacks kind
of no i couldn't even guess i would bet
that would be around there maybe at
least 30 i would bet
30 to cruise in yeah and if you just
lost your job i think you're like all
right i'll take it well he was a b was
[ __ ] he went on the pulsar podcast
after that and we just spitting out
sponsors
i'll tell you something that gets under
my gizzard bro
and i'll tell you this
that sometimes you get subscriptions and
they redo without you doing it
they re-up they get you they re-up
you order that you know whatever it is a
diet pepsi subscription and they keep
sending it to you but it's one in one
box of it
well thankfully uh
that's changing thanks to true bill
trubill is the new app that helps you
identify and stop paying for
subscriptions you don't need one or
simply forgot about that's right
on average people save up to 720 a year
with true bill
yeah because sometimes it sneaks through
you don't know
four years later you've been playing
you're paying for uh you know uh
what is it called uh dance dance
revolution
um club
anyway
uh because companies make subscriptions
hard to cancel true bill makes it
incredibly simple just link your
accounts and truebill will cancel your
unwanted subscriptions in one tap that's
right
truebill has over 2 million users and
help save them over 100 million
dollars that's a lot
don't fall for subscription scams a lot
of scammers out there people burglars
start canceling today at truebill.com
t-h-e-o
go right now truebill.com
theo it could save you thousands a year
is your uh are you still in the same
spot in l.a same studio are you moving
uh i think we're moving actually
i got a house in nashville now oh [ __ ]
that's right so you go back and forth
yeah go back and forth so that is that
tough do you feel like you're at home
like more home and at one or the other
it's like i literally like having two
different worlds kind of is it kind of
sick though uh it's nice because you can
like okay i'm here and i'm doing this
for a couple weeks and then i'm here i
bet that is kind of nice this is kind of
cool and you get to meet like totally
different people it's like a lot more of
a down-to-earth vibe in nashville a lot
of beautiful women there
friendly people country music you kind
of get in with a different group uh
kid rock lives there so you get to like
hang out with some real [ __ ] you know
hill animals you know millions of asses
yeah yeah so you
what what's your you've been talking to
many ladies or how do you go about that
yeah i've been doing some dating dude um
what's going on
yeah i've been doing some dating
i'm not sure sometimes i feel like i
want to have more of like a real spouse
you know yeah
so i'm even thinking more like wife hunt
a little twenty twenty two yeah
you know
oh god it's hard though because you meet
a girl
one time she's on her best behavior
she's not on her period she's not hungry
like she's especially especially when
you're already popular
i'm so thankful i met danny before i had
money before anything before i was
anyone like i met danny she liked me
you know for who i was and then that was
nice i mean it's hard dating trying to
find an actual partner
now that you're you know you're a
celebrity
i bet it's
trickier
yeah i think i've always had a pretty
good feel for like real thotty type of
chicks or some chick that's just after
you know like
i think and i want more like i'm like
i'm thinking like a mother to a child
you know i'm saying i start thinking
about that kind of stuff matt chickens
are good oh dude
i've already every time i see a mexican
i'm like i want to be mexican you know
yeah oh every time i tell them straight
up dude and they i technically am
mexican though
really yeah cause like danny's mexican
i'm white
we had a baby yeah elena's half mexican
we have the same dna
therefore i'm half mexican this sounds
like sweet ufc math dude
um i will say this though dude what if
you started [ __ ] looking mexican dog
i'm trying crazy bro you gotta know i
think you got to do the um mexican
colors in the hair yeah i think we could
we could do something and you got to get
like a prison thing god i should have
kept my [ __ ] tat i had a tat right
here that said something brown pride
carnal or something you need one like uh
oh yeah conor nala what's the one they
always put or
familia yeah yeah you need something
hard bro amelia and you need like just
two mexican kids like walking behind you
at all times
i mean we might have another one someday
yeah yeah you never know do you guys
think about it well honestly after
watching the kardashians it makes me
want to have like they're seeing the
sisters relationship it's funny because
they're always [ __ ] arguing fighting
but
it just makes you want like super cool
like me and my brother and sister like
we have our own our relationships it
makes you [ __ ] kind of want to have a
little tribe yeah but i also want to
just get like a black girl pregnant an
asian girl i want to have like a bunch
of different danny doesn't really like
that but
accidents happen you know what i mean do
you like kim kardashian's butt
what do you mean would i
sit on it no do you like it would you
would you be like yeah i wanna i want
that butt oh i'd be on that thing would
you i'd be on it like that dude that
puts out the like the orange land
equipment and he's like lining up things
and stuff like that like when they're
building the sidewalk yeah i would be
like and he leaves something overnight
for some reason like what the [ __ ] i
heard kim and pete might not be doing
too good is that true dude she rolled up
to the party sans pete you know and she
looked like exactly like you thought
like this this uh just a queen because
the party you got there and then you had
to go up she was there she was there she
rolled in with like bat girl talk to her
batgirl heidi klum her
and somebody else there was just so much
like finesse i couldn't even see after
the third person
like it was literally you talk to her
hey hi here you go no ah
i don't know if she saw me it was really
really fast i met her before years ago
but i don't know if she would remember
damn kim
we were trying to catch her attention at
all at the party trying to do a little
something no because we were leaving
when they was coming in i would have
fell in front of her or something oh
dude they had something
i mean they just had so many like um
i mean just er
kevin bacon i mean just so many
the whole party was absolutely just
it was a it was like i don't even know
any of those people you named yeah but
leonardo dicaprio i've heard of him
um why do you say that like you want to
[ __ ] him
but i think also that day yeah
that's fine could you if you had to go
for a big dog like that who would you go
for because i feel like if you showed up
in the afternoon when i'm would [ __ ] you
yeah leo
not at night though at night there's a
level of diceyness that comes with this
yeah but you show up afternoon time
with a tennis thing on oh
and your gold chain
i mean that's a different world out
there isn't it those kind of really
parties just like oh it was you could
tell that they could just we've never
been they could afford anything they
could cure aids if they wanted to you
could just smell it in the air like they
even had like little hors d'oeuvres like
oh these curades if you want one you're
like damn it's like why should we tell
people about that no no no it's just for
us just for us they had all of it bro
they had stem cells they were running
around the whole place was just there's
iv stations oh it was oh it was magical
yeah it was magical and there was a
couple somebody had let in a couple
straight busters bro just some [ __ ]
real animal dudes bruh just regular guys
like him and eyes and this yeah oh just
regular like as if it's and the funniest
thing is the dudes knew me immediately
right so i was like oh that's my crowd
baby
and this dude is just over there i think
he's from ireland or something he's just
doing rails off this table by himself
and then it's like that's us like
20 minutes later
he was just looking just like this and
he was holding his girl's hand but like
with the straightest arm ever like he
was so gay like he might have had a
little fentanyl in there oh yeah bro
like he was early to that fentanyl
do you all run a fentanyl test or have
jx or somebody do a little bump first or
how do you guys run it yeah tim usually
takes care of that yeah
no no we're [ __ ] drug free
have you had a night where like that was
too much like yes did you go to the er
ever no yeah you think about it
i've thought about it no
the er i mean i i'd always know i'm
gonna come around give me a couple days
i'm gonna [ __ ] be all right
yeah yeah you do ivs much well you don't
really [ __ ] do do much you don't do
adderalls you don't do
scotch-free on the drugs besides
caffeine
uh oh i did ayahuasca
so i went and did an ayahuasca ceremony
so that's a drink in peru uh i just did
i did that [ __ ] right off the 101 in l.a
dude
i'm not even joking dude i was 180 feet
from like a um paw paws actually
you could smell the like in the
afternoon like i guess three times a day
they do biscuits over there when they do
like the bakes
and um you could smell them at each time
and it would definitely liven up the
freaking ayahuasca vibe
you'd be sitting there just bawling
crying and suddenly it's just like has
this whole biscuity vibe yeah
that's funny um that was pretty next
level i'm sure there's a lot of it out
here in the desert because a lot of
there's a lot of like bootleg indians
out here yeah that's the ayahuasca kind
of kind of scares me i would i think i'm
gonna you know i'll do it eventually i'd
like to go and do it like peru go into
the jungle and [ __ ] do it for maybe
wait till after fighting yeah well
tucson they got a lot of peyote down
there man yeah toushon yeah
i used to live down there
i think we've
really been down there too much what is
it two hours from us today tucson yeah
we don't really go down there too much
it's a lot of like
i remember was a lot of like men with
dream catchers which was an interesting
vibe you know you don't see that with
men
and what else dude a lot of people uh
a lot of people like making rock shapes
in their yard kind of like rock stacking
yeah like yeah different
like little baby uh like that's their
landscape it's just like some rock stack
yeah like baby what are those things
called baby altars or like little altars
and stuff kind of some jesus [ __ ]
not quiet more like moon wolf [ __ ] okay
a lot of moon wolf junkies down there
um a lot of feather you know feather
[ __ ] like that
uh feather [ __ ]
yeah like
i like all sorts of i'm not really picky
what about you about what women oh you
want to talk about women then i see you
you [ __ ] want to talk about the
puss huh well it's just on my mind 24 7.
is it really um my testosterone level i
feel like pretty high i think i
constantly
you know if i can bust if we could if i
could bust a good solid twice in a day
and then the next day i feel like i'll
be like kind of normal and then like
it'll my test or my chi will start
building up again but
it's on my mind a lot
like just smashing biscuits
do you will you refuse to uh touch
yourself with your own hand i'd
have it in a long nah yeah i have it in
a while been been using danny have you
done the oculus porn i've done the
oculus porn one time but it wasn't like
it was just it was basically just
watching so far like the pornhub on the
oculus so it wasn't like you were
walking around the room the oculus porn
i did that once it was really cool is it
scary
uh
no
no i i well
pops up depends what pops up
is it like almost too real that you're
like oh man i don't know if this would
be uh
if i keep coming back to this it could
get addictive does it make you not want
to interact with the oculus porn yeah
well it's the way the i don't know if
there's like different oculus porn where
you can actually like feel you like
you're actually there so i was just
basically the one i watched was like not
watching porn like this
so you do feel kind of like you're in
the room but it's not as if you are
right like i think you could there's
probably different oculus porn to where
it's like whoa i just [ __ ] her right
like maybe you put on a full body suit
and certain interactions happening see
that would be great that would be
dangerous because then i'd be smart like
kim or whatever yeah or i mean that's
gonna happen soon certain holes around
the house that that oculus leads you to
oh
well that and then that's gonna be like
you'll pay a certain amount and you'll
be able to have sex with this person or
you'll get this will happen
you know or something like a certain pay
pay a certain amount to some girls only
fans and you can oculus [ __ ] yeah yeah
i'd do that
or then are you subscribed to any chicks
uh only fans i've gotten on there two
times and then deleted it immediately
after i fell in love with my own body
yeah
dear lord jesus please forgive my friend
theo for the sunset but yeah dude that
[ __ ] makes you feel dark when you're out
there just because once you shut your
phone down and stuff you just feel def
it feels like a defeat it's different
than having sex yeah jay and off is
different sometimes though like honestly
i just need to to be able to carry on
throughout the day i just really get it
out the way hit up a little bit if my
back sore i need a massage
i'll go there just to and like i'll
leave and i'll be like oh i can focus i
can go stream i'm gonna play i can go
play video games with the boys i can
work on my merch i can shoot a blog but
i just gotta get that out the way
sometimes and that could be also one of
the things what makes you like a fighter
like do you just have that uh that's
that other level of because if you got a
jackie ejaculate
two times in a day that seems like i
don't have to what do i mean right but i
should i could right yeah it helps me
feel just like normal i think you know
tim's deals with it similar to i think
it might be being an alpha just a
[ __ ] hardcore training like
and we eat good we sleep good like our
bodies running how it should right well
maybe it's not that too because you do
it do you have an issue with beating off
i don't like beating off that much oh i
would rather keep my and keep my chi
yeah because i just feel like it's like
it feels like a
a weight like not a waste but it feels
like i feel like a waste is a good word
for a waste of that energy i do like
jacking off is that in our minds from
previous
conditioned condition
because do animals jack off
whoa well
my i mean my dog's humping all the time
he was [ __ ] the yoga ball was it yeah
two nights ago
oh yeah well even your girl dog's just
rubbing her little [ __ ] on everything
so animals just so animals if animals
could jack off they wouldn't and um
[Laughter]
i think they would a lot monkeys yeah oh
especially a sloth once you got that
freaking finally got that [ __ ] in his
hand though
i bet monkeys probably put fingers in
their butts and jay off oh
probably
monkeys and rhinos
dude we're just animals just smarter
slash dumber animals yeah with more
capability of getting off what do you
think would be the toughest animal to
fight like in an actual sanctioned bout
like a like similar size animal probably
dude monkeys monkeys are
they're so athletic they do so much [ __ ]
they're so strong well let's go
non-primate then because a monkey's just
like a human like outside of that what
would be the toughest animal to really
go google [ __ ] with an elk
i [ __ ] hook up buffalo but elk have
them horns so you'd be able to manage
their head and they're you know you're
gonna be able to have connect that
control [ __ ] stomach
yeah
yeah elk would be tough turtle would be
tough too because they can just you
wouldn't be able to get like a good shot
off well you wouldn't be able to get um
take their back yeah yeah because they
would just keep putting their porcupine
would [ __ ] be hard to take their back
oh you know what i mean
you imagine you [ __ ] up and take a
porcupine's back
i mean you would he wouldn't be able to
get you off yeah or you wouldn't be able
to get off i guess yeah
i don't know dude you want kids i guess
you got to find that right blue thing
right yeah i think so man i think it's
sometimes it looks like i think i put
more like pressure into it than it is
you know right because like you just had
were you expecting to have a child no
accident yeah
and it seems like it's been a real
blessing it was probably the biggest
blessing in my life because i got a lot
of money a lot of fame shortly after
that to where i don't know if i would
have been able to really stay home stay
grounded excited humble you know what i
mean but i'm more grounded yeah just
because you meet guys like steve and
[ __ ] kyle and six nine and [ __ ]
bradley and [ __ ] logan and jake and
like you have all these opportunities
like yo come to puerto rico y'all come
to miami yo come hang out with 42 doug
like steve text me he's like yo get on a
plane come hang out little baby and 42
doug
i'm like [ __ ] yeah i could yeah i could
be there in six hours but you know
having elena and danny [ __ ] keeps me
just like
it really what it is after my fights i
deal with way more anxiety i deal with
anxiety because my sleep schedule's not
as good
i'm [ __ ] partying i'm drinking i'm
doing alcohol and uh i deal with anxiety
but when i'm in this phase where i'm at
right now training consistently like my
body's healthy i can train
i don't really have that anxiety i'm not
i'm comfortable with everything with my
life so but i'm still go like after my
next fight i'm still gonna go partying
no i'm gonna have that anxiety i'm gonna
have deal with that [ __ ] and everything
that comes with that life
but i always know like i can always it
takes me about two weeks to kind of if i
just do the same routine that i know i
can be content
with with life so yeah having elena
saved my [ __ ] life and i i truly
believe that because i'm a crazy
[ __ ] dude i'm scared of sugar
sometimes like i don't want to let sugar
out really i get nervous when i think
about like after my fights i'm like okay
sometimes i'm like dude i don't want to
party don't don't make me do this and i
really i want to but i'm also like i i
don't want to because that leads to
right you don't know how how far you how
far you'll go yeah each time it goes a
little bit further too well this time
was a little bit less pride than last
fight right which not by a lot but it
was a little bit less so maybe i'm
managing it a little bit better but i
also never partied in high school never
partied in college so these are kind of
like my college partying days
yes so that's a lot of pressure because
then you get it now at a point when you
can have access to everything oh it's
it's scary it's a it's dangerous yeah
and yeah with that if elena wasn't in
the picture
it could be a lot worse going back to
you having kids you should just find the
hottest chick knock her up you know what
i mean but the hottest chick is that
necessarily because you're why don't you
get a [ __ ] every time you have to what
oh you get a like
but what if she's a [ __ ] mom though no
that's important you're right i don't
want some i don't want to be driving
around and i got two baby seats and my
wife's in [ __ ] one of them
yeah no that's true
make her make sure she's mexican dude
yeah
and how easy is it to meet a mexican
woman where do you meet him well i mean
la's probably got a lot i mean arizona's
got a [ __ ] on yeah already go you go
down to mexico i bet there's a couple
down there
you know what i mean
yeah
yeah yeah yeah
i would like to go back to i've never
been to mexico because the way danny's
like uh green card is or whatever
like she can't she can't really leave
the country right now she can but
getting back's questionable it's like ah
sounds dicey yeah so it's like we're not
we don't really risk leaving anywhere
but i would love to go to mexico dude i
love mexican women
are you a bone are you uh contractually
like a mexican like can you get a do you
have a mexican
um
passport uh i don't i don't know is
there specific passports i don't know
but danny said elaine is going to be
dual citizens
oh really yeah do mexican do they even
have passport i don't know mexicans just
go wherever they want kind of i don't
know
i don't know dude home depot
it's just like
wherever um that's what i was thinking
for the gym because we got to move all
those mats here we should make a sick
vlog dude pull up in the limo pick up
like seven eight mexicans from home
depot
just like and pay them good and train
them if you did a short training session
with them
put them all in like cool shorts and
stuff that would be fun some sugar gear
get them gassed up bro and then [ __ ]
put them on the mat
one guy's just like
see i got like youtube and vlogs and
[ __ ]
i could i would love to do that
full-time really it would be so fun for
me and i feel like it would be so much
less like pain because training [ __ ]
dude i'm sore every day like every day
you deal with little injuries you
[ __ ] sorry dude being a full-time
youtuber i don't think i would be it
wouldn't be as fulfilling because i
believe my destiny is to be the ufc
champ i have to do that i can't [ __ ]
do anything else i have to do that but i
make vlogs little vlogs here on the side
and [ __ ] but being a full-time youtuber
doing [ __ ] like that being creative
coming up with those ideas like
would be [ __ ] fun and seeing steve
and all those guys just constantly
making banger youtube videos like i get
fomo for sure yeah
we're like god that'd be sick i could be
there i could be making my own [ __ ]
well now you kind of have the boat but
you you have the best of both worlds
right now you know you got both options
so that's really nice
and the one will always be there late i
mean you can always make vlogs yeah
absolutely that's the thing i remind
myself a lot my dude i'm 27 right now
i'm in my prime time 34 35 or whatever
i have to become champ in these years
yeah i don't i can't do it when i'm 40.
i got it right now i got to [ __ ] do
what i got to do and i have to remind
myself that a lot
sometimes get carried away
be like i could just go and do it
something else
it's weird like once you make money you
lose a little bit of that hunger and you
have to find different ways to motivate
you like obviously that money's not the
money i have right now is not gonna last
forever and it's gonna run out but
when you have don't have money it's like
that you're [ __ ] hungry you're
motivated you want to make money yeah
then you make the money you make the
fame whatever and then it's like damn
that's
you run out of a little motivation you
have to find it other places dude that's
why it's so impressive with those
champions that have defended their belt
so many times
yeah or canelo or even a fighter that's
been in it for 10 15 years having to
find that motivation for a fight camp
for that many [ __ ] like to share
to over yeah wow i wonder is that
unbelievable
you know how many senior citizens
started mma that week after he won you
know what i'm saying oh [ __ ] yeah or you
know how many people were like [ __ ]
their wife because they felt
re-empowered you know how many people
like how many like
i mean he's 51 i think or no
glover 45 41 41 42 there's not a huge
exactly exactly exactly
wow
but yeah that's i mean that's to become
a world champion that is older like i
plan on being done fighting before then
he just won the belt it's [ __ ] insane
yeah
and kenny i mean yeah it's like and it
seems like he can keep it because his
last because he had that fight against
lionheart that was a great fight you
know he had a couple
he just beat john bolhovich right yeah
yeah
who does it yeah that was crazy he's got
that is that heavy weight yuri guy next
light heavy oh yeah light heavy oh yeah
that [ __ ] is like three and only
or something yeah i know he's a that's
like young versus old how old is he
actually i don't even know i think he
might be 30 something
do you think at a certain point if
there's a 21 year old dude going out
there fighting a 42 year old that it's
like almost feels like this feels wrong
beat number daddy uh unless that daddy
whoops the sun yep you know what i mean
yeah think if he's champ and there's a
21 year old that's like all right that's
just i mean that's what it is you're the
champ yeah
who do you see yourself having to beat
for the belt like who do you see that
match so you i see i close my eyes i see
me versus peter for the ufc belt i see
that i've seen that for a while
that's just what i think happens do you
think you have any more insight because
you all live in like a desert area like
because desert creates a lot of space in
the brain and it it's not the same in
other places what do you mean um where
you might have a better insight into
actually getting good visions and stuff
out here oh
um
it's a good question i feel like even
when i lived in montana i was like
visualize pretty well is that what we
mean like realize the future and
and stuff if you would ask me 16 years
old will you be in the ufc will you have
money will you have fame i would 100
said yes for whatever reason i seen that
i believed it with all of my [ __ ]
heart you could ask the people i was
surrounded with you could ask my dad my
parents like i believe that maybe
16 maybe now i wasn't through a c it was
like will you be popular and have money
yeah then once i started fighting it was
like oh [ __ ] i'm gonna be in the ufc i
thought i knew or thought i was gonna be
ufc champion before i could even name
the champions in the divisions wow
which was really weird
do you going back to what you said about
like motivation that kind of thing
changed and i noticed that too even with
like
you know you wonder like if uh
even with comedy when the pandemic
started i was like i wonder if i even
wanted to do com it was like because it
finally stopped you know i've been doing
it for 15 years something finally there
was something that made it just you
can't do it
so i think my brain was like
you just started this 15 years ago we
didn't know it would go where it's going
do you even you know do you want to do
something now like your brain starts to
like you just have a moment of where you
can have reflection you know
and is your motivation still the same
um well i haven't got the belt yet so
like that that i have to remind myself
like i i need i i'm going to be the
champion i have to become a champion
that just has to happen
but it's interesting with you because it
almost seems like it's just about you
it's not about these other whoever else
is in the way it doesn't mat they're not
really fixtures in your world as much
it's
i mean it really is kind of the sugar
show it's just like this is what i see
and so i have to yeah well it's weird
because i it's am i i feel like i'm the
[ __ ] champ i live like i'm the champ
i'm like okay we gotta remind yourself
whoa whoa whoa you're not actually a
champ i gotta remind myself that like i
feel like i'm the [ __ ] champ i live
like i feel like i'm living like i'm the
champ i got the house i want the cars i
want whatever like i'm [ __ ] banging
two chicks the same time like i'm like
i'm the champ but i'm like whoa whoa
whoa we still gotta [ __ ] keep
preparing keep training
gotta get that i still gotta be the
champ i gotta wear that belt
do you find it harder to motivate him
uh
i don't think so because he's smart
enough to know it's not like i gotta
call him hey you gotta [ __ ] train hey
you gotta train he's smart enough to
know that how much growth he still has
because he still come into jiu jitsu and
you get humbled or you come into
practice be like damn this guy [ __ ] me
up there's still a lot of growth left so
not too bad right now what is it
probably 14 weeks till your next fight
yeah as long as we're staying consistent
at least i mean six seven practices a
week compared to eight or nine or ten
yeah that's good yeah because you can't
train like this far out you can't train
like
you can't train like you're in fight
camp you just can't do it you can't keep
that pace for that long and you
shouldn't it's not good overtraining is
a real [ __ ] thing
so right now i'm
like i say i train nine times in a week
for fight camp right now i'm training
six seven
you know you know what i mean oh so i'm
not over training i was dealing with
quadriceps tendinitis in my [ __ ] knee
since that last fight just recently like
the last time what's that from weed
quadriceps tendonitis yeah yeah from
smoking weed no it's from uh just
tendonitis overuse like i said i had
three fights last year so just [ __ ]
on it so much
recently the last three weeks i've been
able to train hard consistently like
going to
comp training and going back to the mma
lab and wrestling with those guys and
[ __ ] so
yeah i guess you really have to pay yeah
now it's like everything's become a lot
more of a science like okay you know the
fight is then you have the eight weeks
or however many weeks you're gonna train
before it you know kind of like where
you need to be at the beginning where
you need to be at four weeks six weeks
and then seven weeks eight weeks is
important those eight weeks like from
right now what i do for the next eight
weeks i definitely gotta improve but
what's the most important is those
[ __ ] eight weeks in training camp
getting in the best shape possible yeah
that's the most important part and it
sucks thinking like i have 14 weeks it's
like that seems like so long dude i
wonder how many bantamweight fights are
on the phoenix card they could stay say
five weeks you had to prep just like
some random guy pulls out yeah the thing
that sucks too about
moving up in the rankings it's like
for me i have two more fights in my
country i want to fight i want to be as
close as possible to the title by the
time that ends up really why
because that's you know that's just
negotiation reasons leverage like i if
i'm coming off two more kos going in to
renegotiate my contract like i'm gonna
get a fat [ __ ] contract i lose my
next two fights to
random people it doesn't look good like
right but but do you have to be cl as
close to the title as possible or does
it help you to fight like guys that are
like just the next one and the next one
that's why pedro seems like that that
next fight that makes the most sense
yeah when it comes negotiation time do
other like promotions get
like an alert how do they find out
you're a free agent and then they just
start sending offers and then the ufc
counters them yeah the thing with the
ufc is like they don't want it to go to
there they want to sign they want to
re-sign you before your contract's up so
bellator or one or whatever other
company
because right now they can't offer me
hey we'll pay you this much because i'm
under contract ufc i can't not talk to
anyone else they're illegal
so i say i fight out my two fights and
now i'm a free agent whether they hear
that from me or they pay attention or
whatever
um and i i ah yeah i don't know um yeah
because what could they really probably
all yeah like what i'm wondering
but yeah even it's just stay competitive
as a business they would have to
probably make some offer yeah yeah and i
want i want to stay in the ufc i want to
be in the ufc it's where i belong that's
i want to be ufc champ i want to defend
the title i want to move up i want to be
in the ufc so like obviously
it's just it's leverage it's like that
they offer me this much like will you
match the will the ufc match that
hopefully you know ideally i have a good
relationship with them they know what
i'm worth so if they see like yeah that
makes sense like it's just
let's just leverage yeah
but yeah i mean ufc's [ __ ]
been nothing but good to me i [ __ ]
love to see usc dana white's the best
[ __ ] president
in all of sports oh he's great dude i
got to go to i go i went over to ufc and
got to go in there and be in the ufc
just everywhere you know and at the
fight like in the green room or what no
at the um yes i got to do that but i
also got to just go to the apex go to
like their offices and stuff and meet
with them we're talking about maybe
trying to do something together you know
um and so
uh
we went and talked with them and then we
got and dana came in the room it was
really really cool dana fires you up oh
yeah he's just a [ __ ] character oh i
wanted to fight the other two guys in
the room and they [ __ ] worked at ufc
dude
i was like i'll [ __ ] fight either one
of these little [ __ ]
chair monsters right now son
uh
yeah he does the whole place fires you
up man we got to go over and just just
see all that just where everybody kind
of practice where they shoot all the you
know cool promos and stuff pi is [ __ ]
sick dude i love going there we're
actually going to vegas friday because
first competition but we're gonna try to
pop by the pi it's always just a fun
place to get the hot cold to get the
lunch when did they do they built that
what four or five years ago now it's
crazy how much it
i wonder what deal that they got that
that just [ __ ] grew so much because
seven years ago eight years ago
cornering guys and being with guys in
the ufc it's like you didn't have that
you go to a hotel you get one room with
two beds for your whole team
there's no pi yeah there's no
nutritionist to help you with your
nutrition it's just well they sold for
four billion remember so that's probably
win huh oh who wouldn't wme i think yeah
so uh do you know you april 16th and
vincent lucas belle mohammed main event
i didn't know that did you i was looking
i was trying to look at the phoenix card
to see if there's bandwidth on it
that's a sick fight vincent luke evers
below muhammad that's like a title
eliminator those are venom venomous
welterweights that's uh kamaru
oh wow but i didn't know that fight was
even happening what do y'all see with
this geichi uh oliveira whoo that's here
you going uh i have for two shows i'm so
angry but i have two shows that we're at
in l.a in l.a yeah that's gonna be a
banger i'll wear a little earpiece and
commentate the fight for you while
you're on stage yeah dude i uh uh
even at the get the oliveira uh poirier
fight
gaity was back there you could tell he's
just
ready to fight like as if at that moment
one of them couldn't make it in he would
be like i will go in right now oh 100
dude that guy i don't know if there's
anybody who's like i will go in right
now more than him yeah dude that phoenix
card is [ __ ] sweet
there's donald cerrone uh joe lozon
that's an interesting fight uh
michael chandler tony ferguson that's
all the same fight rose versus carla
charles that's may 7th
may 7th
yeah what do you think happens with that
one timmy what do you think which which
one just with the uh gaitre oliveira god
[ __ ] oliveira has that muay thai
stance where he doesn't really move his
head and like a good hard-hitting boxer
like justin and charles you see him get
always get dropped but then he wins but
then he gets dropped and people don't
want to go into his guard so they drop
him and he can lay there from his back a
little bit and get his wits about him
and then stand back up it's [ __ ]
insane i feel like justin could beat
charles but i feel like justin would
have a tough time beating islam but i
feel like charles could potentially give
islam [ __ ] trouble oh dude that
division's sick too it's just mma math
is crazy yeah well islam just riding up
that i mean he is literally like i'm
sure they're all like how are we going
to be
yeah yeah he'll be [ __ ]
he's a gamer gilbert's coming
up
yeah and i don't oh yeah and i don't see
how that how
i don't know
i don't see how anybody beats these
these russian guys are the dagger
stanions yeah they're damn
you know they don't even have they got
semen eyelids man these people are
[ __ ] wild bro semen eyelids
it's a sick tap
yeah
but yeah i think gilbert if someone's
going to beat hazmat gilbert's got you
know
the best chance besides kamaru yeah
colby versus hump uh calm shot it's an
interesting but like
he's never comes out hasn't beat
anybody near gilbert's level so if he
goes out there and beats gilbert it's
like oh
[ __ ] how good is gilbert with wrestling
he could wrestle like a [ __ ] he
can and like calm down high levels comes
out took the jingling guy and [ __ ]
toss him around but so did neil magney
neil magnus not a big powerful guy and
he [ __ ] smacked around jingling too
yeah but dude
it's gonna it's gonna tell a lot about
cons on this fight wow he's yeah i mean
okay it's on the seventh two no no i
don't know when that one is that one's
is that one sooner oh it's april 9th oh
that one's the last week that one's the
peter aljo next weekend oh that's gonna
be wild that's a good one who's uh main
event of that
oh that's alexander bolanovsky if his
korean zombie damn mackenzie during
teacher taurus kelvin gaslum oh that
fight got canceled is there a female
fighter that you think could beat you
out there
or has there been in the history fema in
any weight class
probably not no
you you you feel you if you go with a
girl like a black belt world champion
girl you feel the just the difference
so now right you always wonder what
that's like but cyborg i mean she could
give a lot of guy [ __ ] problems i
think yeah she's because she's tall was
she five eight five nine and she she
punches like a guy yeah
but man and unions [ __ ] knocked her
out man he was a beast too but yeah
probably not
um we'll finish up man i was just
thinking about this if you had a [ __ ]
marry kill anak dc
and bisping man how do you roll that out
with those beautiful men um
and it's gonna be sad to see one of them
go yeah dc we we have uh we have a
love-hate relationship i'll kill him all
right i couldn't actually because he
could you know beat me up unfortunately
oh yeah he's that freaking hearty
pudding podcast
um
basically an anec annik and i are boys i
i really like bisping too unfortunately
i wouldn't i just really wouldn't like
to [ __ ] either of them yeah you know
what i mean they're not cute yeah but
think about it a little more yeah yeah i
would [ __ ] them i mean
i'm just saying think about like you
know at least go to dinner don't make it
all about just the sex like say if you
had to do an evening oh one of them who
would it be i feel like i'd get along
with all three of them really me and dc
would have a little back and forth i'd
probably have to [ __ ] hit him in a
little single leg maybe switch to a
double leg
if you're talking marriage i mean anik
would probably
be the one yeah anik would be that
little thought kind of or he'd be like
that kind of like a little pretty boy
you take out yeah yeah a little sassy
boy yeah and bisping would be that um
you know the his eye and [ __ ] if it fell
out for him
yeah but that would almost be romantic
like oh honey
yeah yeah shine it yeah but he was the
champ too is that a belt you gotta
remember him oh the count bro he looked
good in that jewel he'll bri he'll be
wearing his own jewelry have you ever uh
listened or read his book uh-uh very
good very good book really really
enjoyed that book
talked about you know him growing up and
you know winning the title and [ __ ] it's
really good book yeah he's fascinating
man he used to be a dj too man he came
on the podcast once we were talking
about when he was a dj at like a
nightclub and [ __ ] god dude i feel like
that's something i could do too be a
little dj just get the crowd [ __ ]
hype dude just [ __ ] flopping my
wiener out there it's like well i don't
think you can get your dick out but no i
think my club oh
do you what if you had your pubic hair
the exact same way as you had your own
hair that'd be cool
i do
i color it just some bangs nobody knew
yeah
that would be cool though a little curly
[ __ ] you're like damn that dick looks
like it has a sick crossover damn
cornrow it for my fights um so finish it
off for me then so you got dc will pass
away so then you're down you're down to
bisping who do you marry uh
i mean
long term you really have to think about
you the
i don't know should we say [ __ ] or
should we say uh something else
that's just like really hurting my head
stand there on the porch when somebody
leaves you have to do that okay let's
just stand there together wave by
i don't know i'd probably do that i'd
probably marry anik i feel like we could
just commentate fights all night
together yeah yeah oh yeah anna would
stay you wouldn't be able to get any
rest though he would just be up
commentating all dude he does some
serious research and like some serious
homework for that [ __ ] oh he's amazing
bisping hangs sleeps upside down i heard
so oh
basically like his alcohol dude yeah
so he might abuse you he might beat my
eye yes so i think you got to go with
that because that would be good for
sparring so i think you marry bisping
okay i think you bang anak ah
sorry you know it is what and you can
bang them again you know choose
and then
dc would have a beautiful funeral too
because he's from louisiana it would be
a very like the musical presence there
he'll be eating good yeah let me ask you
this [ __ ] mary kill
kim kardash
uh brittany palmer
okay and give me another one the artist
uh uh uh megan fox
but don't say don't be mean because he's
she's dating uh machine gun kelly so
okay and just be thoughtful yeah megan
fox i think would be out i'm just she's
not my vibe to kill her beautiful lady
so i would have someone else kill her
but she would not be megan around okay
um and i would probably do a poison so
it's not like something violent that he
could still look nice
yeah okay
so i would go that and then
kim and brittany palmer it's like wow
which one you want to smash bisque uh
i'd probably want to s well with kim
your marriage isn't going to last so you
don't know that you do statistically
speaking you might think that but you
don't know that dude she's over is she
over two or over three with marriages
yeah
so so i mean i mean
he can't i think i would probably
but then you're gonna be living that
kardashian life so you have to be on the
show you're gonna have to i would love
to be oh no but say someone like you
didn't sign a prenup do you get half her
cheddar yeah if you slide in the right
way i don't think i could make love good
enough to not to beat a prenup yeah like
you got to [ __ ] good to be the preacher
the cardi b style [ __ ] wow
yeah you gotta really imagine [ __ ]
kim and telling your friends
i hope she'd feel it
i you
they got that reparations vagina baby
that thing is definitely
giving back yeah yeah
um
i think i'd probably marr i'd probably
marry britney palmer then maybe i don't
know i've never met her in person what
is she like i met her
i met her one time after my after that
last fight at the club and i was faded
but i thought we were vibing
i thought we were bi but i shot our dm
one time when i was in vegas at one of
the fights and oh probably i didn't get
it back yeah i didn't get the dm back i
was [ __ ] low-key kind of sad
yeah then i would probably yeah maybe i
think she does art too so maybe that
would be nice to hang some art up i
don't know kim's a lawyer so she
do you not see pete's tat
yeah but i don't know if that's i don't
know if that's a little no i think she's
like legit went to school and [ __ ] oh
damn so it's kind of hard really no
that's really stressful it's like [ __ ]
what's the big case you're working on
when did she go to school and grind when
she's born that rich i i think yeah i
want to say she actually is pretty smart
and [ __ ] she might have heard like some
word slave or something dude yeah okay
you know what i'm saying or something
because you can do that you can like go
study and then you can i think if you're
rich you can do you can get whatever
well didn't she go to the white house
and like actually help a lot of innocent
people out i think so i think she met up
with trump and helped some people get
out of jail if you had say you had one
time to smash kim kardashian's biscuits
okay
and you were guaranteed i could get her
pregnant okay
would you
i would i probably would i'd be like why
would i do that stressful added to my
life i don't know if i could help myself
yeah the stress would be intense why
because then you i mean that's just like
you said you're on the show you're
dealing with kanye you're dealing with
pete the kids life is all is going to be
all over the place yeah i would do it
though just because i have no self
[ __ ] discipline i would do it i think
you'd have to do it to see what it would
all be like you know if the kid would
even yeah but i think here's my question
is you're gonna bang kim kardashian
right she's coming up to the hotel room
where are you in the hotel room before
she walks in are you sitting in the
chair naked are you and you have to be
naked right are you i would be do you
you pretend you're just doing something
in the bathroom and then she come and
you walk out like or do you lay in the
bed like what would you do could i be
drunk that's a great question um no no
sir you have to change it
i feel like sober i feel pretty can get
goofy drunk i'm the funniest
[ __ ] alive after you for me i'd
have my robe open and act surprised when
she walked in
would you be hard
half
nice that's good that's good i would
probably be playing some [ __ ] ac dc
oh yeah
just jamming
no i'd be i'd be playing some um on your
phone playing music on your phone i
think he's such a poor mood but i'd play
it on my phone i play kanye loves kanye
that song
i'd put it in a bowl so it's a little
bit louder yes i would uh i would have
the
ice thing put it in that ice bowl oh
that's a good idea that's a good tune
out of the curtains open overlooking the
city probably in vegas because it would
be after a fight yeah um and you'll be
beaten a little bit i'd be sore yeah my
[ __ ] hands would be sore from just ko
and like three people in a row would
your dick be wrapped in tape or not no
no dick's ready to rock okay no what
about you huh
i think i haven't thought about this
well let me tell you
i don't know i think i'd uh
she's coming she said i just i'm coming
up the elevator now
i think you almost want to be looking
out the window so they see your ass when
they come in i think that's kind of just
a funny move
because if they see your dick right you
walk in i think you look so helpless
kind of in a weird way yes i got a like
a fat little butt yeah no not my seggy
butt i got to be i always get danny
always so you could separate your legs a
little bit if you're kind of looking out
there maybe pointing at something a leg
up yeah
and i'll be like i would turn him like
oh a lot of flights tonight you know or
something like that something that
sounds like
like
aeronautics
so
so
see then you almost want to go kim with
the bang because you can have that one
magical i just don't know the turmoil
after that what it's like i'd be wearing
two watches too
yeah like a cartier and like um
an ap oh out of a house rush bracelet on
my dick that's what they're used to
that's true that's totally what they're
used to
yeah and i think i mean kim matt we'd
get along oh i think that they that they
would really like i i remember that she
was really nice whenever i met her we
have some mutual friends um but i i also
like pete we gotta respect pete yes come
on now let's be respectful but yeah i
think
yeah i mean if they're still seeing each
other you don't even know yeah if not i
mean then we're good yeah so so
um guys i think we really covered a lot
oh i was just about to start talking
about caitlyn jenner oh you were well
that's it now here's one thing you run
into though if you s if you in a good
way you're married to kim you probably
would never meet her dad
uh oh [ __ ] wait you can't take that
no kim kim's that did pass away i apolo
that was [ __ ] up i meant um kylie and
kendall's
dad is caitlin yeah
okay
was the lawyer in the o.j simpson case
which you could write which is yeah you
couldn't make love to the other one like
either way you're not going to have a
chance to date one of the other
daughters though damn yeah i think i
could persuade i think i could if i read
some e40 lyrics i think i could like
really like possibly i think i could do
it
but would you think if you were about to
bank him you could say all right kendall
it's almost like a um
what's behind like i am willing to wager
this chance to
uh make love to kim
to have a chance to bang you you think
she would accept would it would that be
kind of like romantic like wow this
guy's giving up this to have a chance to
take me out especially the way they're
competitive
yeah i think i don't know [ __ ] i mean
who's the cutest kylie
no kendall yes kendall's cute kendall is
the duh like you know i like kylie kim
got that desert fat on her brother they
got that desert that's that's that's
what episode
what season did you really start liking
kendall
at an adult time of course well yeah
because it's weird like 2006 they're
like 11 years old so what season
when they're 18 seven years after that
it's [ __ ] weird
dude you know what
i saw i went and saw that guy oliver
tree the other night have you ever seen
him i've recently seen him from the from
the impulsive podcast yeah he's in the
show is insane
like his music like his concert the
whole thing yeah it's absolutely looks
like a character it's like jonbenet
ramsay kind of like he could be john
renee ramsey first of all
it's like jonbenet ramsey's on ella is
on doing dmt or something at a farm yeah
yeah i would like to i mean he looks
like a character seems like goofball he
is bro the show is fire i wonder if he
gets pug
i mean
is that hair real
he's got a lot going on i don't know you
know what i mean i think that would
determine a lot he's got a lot going on
dude
i think i don't know if he can get
erections though somebody said he can't
get erections i'd probably kill myself
i don't know big call of duty i would go
ch if you can't get erections i would
get the sex change then right so just
get [ __ ] take some d yeah at least
sorry sounds insane now but at least
then you can still [ __ ] you know or you
get [ __ ] yeah no no no bro you're not
getting [ __ ] you'd come at it with a
hard-ass vagina you'd be like i got that
hard [ __ ] son yeah yeah i'm gonna [ __ ]
you yeah yeah yeah yeah so you'd have to
like kind of really do some reversing
like you'd have to learn how to twerk
like a [ __ ] man tim loves twerking on
his girl's face oh damn really no i
don't
wonder if chicks are into that man some
of them tim reminds you the guy that
used to come to the arcade and get all
the quarters out of the machines dude
but also loki be trying to [ __ ] some of
the people that are in there
like i said people not girls yeah yeah
yeah thank you
every compliment thank you uh thank you
guys so much man dude it's great to see
you guys it's just so interesting when i
was watching the previous time with that
that we potted and uh and you were there
too tim and just seeing kind of where
you were then what's going on now um
what was that over a year ago i mean
over it was two years ago it was june in
2020 i want to say yeah
okay that was right after i fought eddie
weinland i think right out there put
himself right okay damn that was a while
ago so thanks for what are you doing out
here i guess we it's been a neat
trajectory we just had a meeting so uh
[ __ ] yeah yeah just honored to be able
to pop in dude see the sugar show um and
timbo man thank you guys so much and uh
we'll see you guys in the future baby
thanks brother all right guys
now i'm just floating on the breeze and
i feel i'm falling like these leaves i
must be
cornerstone
oh but when i reach that ground i'll
share this piece of mind i found i can
[Music]
a little time
for me to set that parking brake
and let myself
i'll sit and tell you my story
[Music]
[Music]
and now i've been moving way too fast on
the runaway train with a heavy load of
my
pants
and these wells that i've been riding on
they want something that their damn
[Music]